es tut mir unendlich leid das sagen zu
müssen aber die Zeit der großen
Konflikte scheint zurückgekehrt zu
sein von der russischen Invasion in der
Ukraine über den Krieg in Gaza und den
annektionsbestrebung Venezuelas bis hin
zum Großkonflikt der sich im Kaukasus
zusammenbraut oder der drohenden
Invasion Taiwans und nicht zu vergessen
die endlosen Scharmützel Staatsstreiche
und Kämpfe die wir überall in Afrika
erleben meine Liebe visual Community die
Welt scheint in Flammen zu stehen und ja
wir alle könnten eine Verschnaufpause
gebrauchen doch die wird uns so schnell
nicht gegönnt werden denn ihr wisst ja
was man sagt Geld ist der Nerv des
Krieges dieser uralte Satz der gemeinhin
dem römischen Philosophen und Politiker
kikero zugeschrieben wird manche nennen
ihn auch cizero erklärt aktuelle
Nachrichten wie diese 20 Oktober 2023
us-hilfen für Israel und die Ukraine das
ist der Inhalt des 105 Milliarden
dollarpakets für die nationale
Sicherheit das beiden gefordert hat 7
September 2023 blinken in der Ukraine
USA kündigen eine Milliarde Dollar an
militärische und ziviler Hilfe an 29
juli 2023 USA kündigen 345 Millionen
Dollar Militärhilfe für Taiwan an 7
dezember 2023 die festgefahrene
Situation im Senat über die Grenzpolitik
bedroht weiterhin die Hilfe für die
Ukraine und Israel denn wenn es ein Land
gibt dass die Kriegs und Geldmaschine am
Laufen hält dann sind das natürlich die
US OFA und wie heißt es so schön wer
zahlt bestimmt die Musik um euch einen
Eindruck zu verschaffen in den letzten
vier Jahren machten die militärexporte
von ankel Sam 40% aller weltweit
gehandelten Waffen
aus wie ihr seht ist der Fluss von US
Rüstungsgütern in den Rest der Welt
doppelt so groß wie der von Russland und
achtmal so groß wie Chinas Marktanteil
wenn es etwas gibt was die Amerikaner
können dann ist es Waffen herzustellen
in dieser Hinsicht sind die USA einfach
un schlagbar aber natürlich verkaufen
die USA nicht nur ihre Waffen sondern
unterstützen damit auch verschiedene
Kriegsanstrengungen sagen wir einfach
dass die Supermacht USA derzeit eine
Menge Kriege führt ohne auch nur einen
einzigen ihrer Männer auf das
Schlachtfeld zu
schicken heute stecken die USA
finanziell und operativ bis zum Hals in
mindestens drei großen Krisengebieten
das erste brauche ich euch nicht zu
erklären das ist die Ukraine zweitens
die Straße von Taiwan und drittens in
Israel das erbnis ist dass das Oval
Office oder besser gesagt dieser ovale
Druckkochtopf jetzt unter wirklich
enormem geopolitischen Druck steht denn
jeder dieser drei Krisenherde braucht
auf seine eigene Weise wirtschaftliche
und militärische Unterstützung durch
Unkel Sam und deshalb haben wir uns hier
bei visualpitik ein paar Fragen gestellt
wie können die USA diese drei
kriegsfronen gleichzeitig
aufrechtterhalten wird der amerikanische
Riese in der Lage sein diese Kampagnen
zu finanzieren und was genau kosten sie
eigentlich heute werden wir hier auf
visualpolitik all diese Fragen restlos
beantworten heute werden wir hier auf
visual Politik all diese Fragen restlos
beantworten und zwar gleich nach der
kurzen Botschaft unseres treuen Sponsors
AG1 denn schließlich hat er das heutige
Video nicht nur mit seinem finanziellen
Beitrag möglich gemacht nein er hilft
weit darüber hinaus was ich meine nun
sicher könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass
dieser Job hier nicht durchzuhalten ist
wenn man sich nicht ordentlich in Form
hält gerade in diesen dunklen
Wintertagen wenn die Sonne schon früh
untergeht und viele von uns mit
Müdigkeit kämpfen ist es cheiden Wege zu
finden um Energie geladen zu bleiben und
mir hilft sowohl meine weihnachtskatze
Angelina als auch
won das aus jahrzehntelanger Forschung
entstanden und bereits 52 mal
weiterentwickeln und optimiert wurde
während des ganzen Arbeitstages im Flow
zu bleiben und mein mentalen Fokus auf
das zu konzentrieren was wirklich zählt
um meinen Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung
zu halten unterstützen mich folgende
Bestandteile meiner allmorgendlichen
Portion AG1 Kupfer Biotin pantetonsäure
tiamin und Vitamine B12 B 2 und C das
ist nicht einfach so daher gesagt
sondern eine evidenzbasierte Tatsache
und wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt dann
schaut euch doch z.B an womit sich jo
Rogan fthält ebenfalls mit AG1 auch in
den Kommentaren unter unseren Videos
schreiben uns immer wieder viele
Zuschauer die AG1 ausprobiert haben und
sehr zufrieden damit sind okay damit
eines klar ist ein
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel ersetzt keine
ausgewogene Ernährung deswegen heißt es
ja nur Ergänzungsmittel aber es hilft
mir eben dabei mit einer gesünderen
Routine unbelastet in den Tag zu starten
allerdings ist AG wohl nicht nur für
meinen individuellen Anwendungsbereich
geeignet sondern bietet auch noch viele
weitere gesundheitliche Vorteile über
die ihr mehr erfahren könnt wenn ihr auf
den Link in der Beschreibung klickt dort
erfahrt ihr auch weitere Details darüber
welche Inhaltsstoffe genau welchen
Nutzen bringen und wie sie optimal
aufeinander abgestimmt sind um
Synergieeffekte und eine hohe bi
Verfügbarkeit zu erzielen fakt ist AG1
ist ketofreundlich und die wertvollen
Mikronährstoffe wurden aus echten
natürlichen veganen Nahrungsmitteln wie
Erbsen oder Soja gewonnen ohne
künstliche Zusatzstoffe außerdem
schmeckt es auch noch gut mir zumindest
natürlich darf man es wie alles nicht
überdosieren sollte auf Allergene achten
und vor allem nicht einnehmen wenn man
schwanger ist oder stillt ich empfehle
euch auf jeden Fall mal eine
Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was genau ihr braucht um
euch besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu
leben mir persönlich hilft die
obengedante Kombination mit
1 am besten denn es deckt meiner Ansicht
nach die meisten Fälle zufriedenstellt
ab passend dazu bietet H1 unserer
Community sogar ein besonderes Angebot
wenn du auf den Link in der video ibung
klickst erhälst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abos einen kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K2 und
fünf praktische H1 travel Packs für
unterwegs gratis neukunden erhalten
außerdem das 1 welcome Kit inklusive
schicke Aufbewahrungsdose und einen
praktischen Shaker das ganze ist ein Abo
ohne laufzeitbindung du kannst es
jederzeit nachbelieben anpassen
pausieren oder kündigen also worauf
wartest du noch probier
noch einfach mal ganz unverbindlich aus
unterstütze auch deine Ernährung auf
einfache und gesunde
[Applaus]
Weise
[Musik]
wann immer es in der Welt Spannungen
gibt sind die USA nur selten nicht
mittendrin es ist das was viele die
Illusion nennen dass sie der Polizist
der Welt sein eine Art Sheriff im
globalen Wilden Westen fakt ist jedoch
dass das US-Militär heute praktisch das
einzige ist dass sich in der Lage sie
Truppen und Ausrüstung einigermaßen
schnell und in großen Umfang in
praktisch jeden entlegenen Winkel der
Erde zu verlegen und es überrascht nicht
dass diese logistisch Kapazität Ihnen
einen großen Einfluss verleiht
einerseits ermöglicht sie es Ihnen
direkt in jeden Konflikt einzugreifen
andererseits können Sie jederzeit jede
ausländische Regierung unterstützen der
Krieg in der Ukraine ist ein gutes
Beispiel dafür aber das müssen wir wohl
hier nicht weiter ausführen denn wenn
wir darüber nachdenken hat es ankelsim
geschafft der ukrainischen Armee
inmitten der russischen Offensive
schnell und große Mengen an
waffenmunition Nachschub aller Art zu
liefern so dass sie sich verteidigen
kann aber natürlich wurden all diese
Kapazitäten nicht über Nacht geschaffen
viel mehr handelt es sich um ein Ziel
das seit den 1940er Jahren angestrebt
wird als Präsident Franklin die roosfelt
die Idee vorantrebt dass die USA zum
Arsenal der Demokratie werden sollten
eine Idee die mehr oder weniger stark
und vielleicht mit Donald Trump als
einziger Ausnahme von allen bisherigen
US-Präsidenten beibehalten
[Musik]
wurde
im Allgemeinen war dies sowohl für
Demokraten als auch für Republikaner
schon immer eine Priorität in gewisser
Weise könnte man sagen dass ich von
roswelt bis Biden und wir müssen uns
dagegen W wie stark sich die Welt
seitdem verändert hat die Formel für
amerikanischen Einfluss in der Welt
konstant geblieben ist ein bisschen
Diplomatie eine Menge Waffen und eine
Prise ich kann vor den Pizzaboten bei
euch sein all das hat natürlich zu
Milliarden schweren Militärausgaben
geführt und auch zur Finanzierung vieler
Konflikte auf der ganzen
Welt tatsache ist dass die US-Regierung
für diese letzte Mission Regeln hat die
bei der Lieferung von Militärgütern in
ein anderes Land eingehalt werden müssen
in erster Linie geht es um den foreign
assistance Act dieses Gesetz erlaubt es
der US-Regierung finanzielle und
materielle Hilfen einschließlich
militärischer Hilfe an ausländische
Länder zu leisten um wenig überraschend
ihre eigenen Interessen zu fördern nun
stellt sich die Frage wie diese
Unterstützung durchgeführt wird nun dazu
gibt es grundsätzlich drei Möglichkeiten
erstens durch die sogenannten foreign
military sales bei diesem Verfahren
genehmigen die USA den Verkauf von
sensiblen Gütern an Verbündete Länder
mit anderen Worten es handelt sich um
kommerzielle Geschäfte um fabrikaufträge
die aber vom Verteidigungsministerium
vermittelt werden zweitens gibt es das
sogenannte foreign military financing in
diesem Fall finanzieren oder
subventionieren die USA in
Übereinstimmung mit den Kriterien des
Außenministeriums direkt den Kauf neuer
us-mitärgüter durch andere Länder und
drittens gibt es die presidential
Drawdown authority diese erlaubt den
direkten Transfer militärischer
Ausrüstung aus dem
usband wenn der Präsident feststellt und
den Kongress darüber informiert dass A
ein unvorhergesehener Notfall vorliegt
der sofortige militärische Hilfe für ein
fremdes Land erfordert und B der
notfallbedarf nicht unter der Autorität
des exportkontrollgesetzes oder eines
anderen Gesetzes mit Ausnahme dieses
Abschnitts gedeckt werden kann kann er
die Entnahme von verteidigungsgütern aus
den Beständen des
Verteidigungsministeriums in einem
Gesamtwert von nicht mehr als 100
Millionen Dollar pro Fiskaljahr anordnen
Abschnitt 56 A1 des foreign assistance
Act ihr haben wahrscheinlich schon
gemerkt dass diese Zahl ein bisschen
klein ist das liegt daran dass dieses
Gesetz schon einige Jahre auf dem Buckel
hat so wurden seit den 1960er Jahren
etwa 20 Änderungen verabschiedet um die
Obergrenzen für Transfers zu ändern im
Jahr 2020 lag diese Zahl bei 11
Milliarden
Dollar aber bei der Differenzierung
zwischen ausländischen militärverkäufen
ausländische militärfinanzierung und
direkten Transfer handelt es sich nicht
nur um eine Formsache denn wie wir
gleich sehen werden handelt es sich um
etwas das in Washington eine zunehmend
hitzige Debatte ausgelöst hat die immer
zahlreicheren militärischen Konflikte
zwingen Washington dazu seine neu zu
mischen die Frage ist also welche
Anforderungen stellen die Ukraine Israel
und Taiwan heute an die usmitärhilfe ist
das Weiße Haus in den anhaltenenden
militärischen Spannungen nicht
überfordert nun ja meine Lieben
Zuschauer dafür müssen wir Punkt für
Punkt vorgehen denn die Wahrheit ist
dass jedes Dossier das in die Hände von
beiden und seinen Beratern gelangt seine
eigenen individuellen Probleme mit sich
bringt fangen wir also mit dem fnen
Osten
an Taiwan der Preis der
Abschreckung die chinesischen Meere
waren in punkto militärische
Abschreckung in den letzten 10 Jahren
die oberste Priorität des
Außenministeriums ironischerweise ist
dies die einzige Region in dem sich die
Interessen der USA zumindest im Moment
noch nicht in einem aktiven Konflikt
befinden in diesem Fall unterscheidet
sich die Verteilung und Zuteilung von
militärischer Ausrüstung an Taiwan stark
von der Zusammenarbeit mit der Ukraine
und Israel zunächst einmal ist die Insel
selbst kein unabhängiges Land zumindest
nicht in den Augen Pekings für das
Regime shishinpings ist die Beziehung
zwischen den USA und Taiwan so etwas wie
die Beziehung zwischen einem souveränen
Land und einer chinesischen Provinz und
das zwingt die Amerikaner dazu bei der
Zuteilung von Geldern und militärischer
Ausrüstung eine Menge juristischer
Tricks anwenden zu müssen zweitens ist
der Einsatzort Taiwanstraße einzigartig
da es sich hier um einen inselkrieg
handelt bei dem die Marine und die
Luftwaffe absolut entscheidend sind ganz
im Gegensatz z.B zur Nützlichkeit der
bodeninfanterie im israelischen und
ukrainischen Krieg es geht also darum
dass sich die USA seit 1979 dazu
verpflichtet haben Taiwan und das ist
ein wörtliches Zitat
verteidigungsartikel und
verteidigungsdienstleistungen in der
Menge zur Verfügung zu stellen die
erforderlich ist damit Taiwan
ausreichende
selbstverteidigungsfähigkeiten
aufrechterhalten kann diese Formulierung
ist ausdrücklich im Taiwan relations Act
festgelegt der vom damaligen Präsidenten
Jimmy Carter unterzeichnet wurde seitdem
wird die militärische Zusammenarbeit mit
Taiwan durch foreign military sales
geregelt mit anderen Worten taiwan ist
ein relativ wohlhabendes Land für seine
Waffenkäufe bezahlen kann was es also
vor allem braucht ist der Zugang zu
moderner Ausrüstung seit Jahrzehnten
sind die us-waffenverkäufer an Taiwan
der sichtbarste Beitrag der USA zu
Taiwans Verteidigungsfähigkeit in den
Jahren 2020 und 2022 war Taiwan der
größte Abnehmer von US foreign military
sales von 1950 bis 2022 war es der
viertgrößte Abnehmer in den letzten
Jahren hat diese Form der Zusammenarbeit
mit Taiwan allerdings viele Zweifel an
ihrer Wirksamkeit aufkommen lassen vor
allem aus zwei
Gründen
[Musik]
zunächst einmal gibt es ein Zeitproblem
es dauert Jahre bis die Bestellungen
geliefert werden nutzlich wurde bekannt
dass potenzielle Verkäufe im Wert von 19
Milliarden US-Dollar in der Pipeline
sind von den einige bis ins Jahr 2016
zurückreichen diese lange Zeitspanne ist
unvereinbar mit einem unmittelbaren
Gefühl der Bedrohung Taiwan auf diese
Weise aufzurüsten bedeutet dass es Jahre
dauern kann bis die Ausrüstung geliefert
wird und einsatzbereit ist z.B wickeln
die USA schon seit 2019 den Verkauf von
mehr als 60 F16 kampflugzeug für Taiwans
Luftstreitkräfte ab und erst im
September 2023 erklärte der
Flugzeughersteller locked Martin dass er
seine Anstrengungen verstärken werde um
wenigstens bis Ende 2025 etwa 4 F16 pro
Monat produzieren zu können und wenn wir
bedenken dass dieses Unternehmen auch
mit Einkäufen aus anderen Ländern wie
der Slowakei und bachrein zu tun hat ist
der Strom von F16 Fighter nach Taiwan
natürlich langsamer als eine atritische
Schildkröte aber das meine Lieben
Zuschauer ist noch nicht
alles
ein potenzieller Krieg in der Straße von
Taiwan würde einen noch nie daagewesenen
logistischen Einsatz erforderern die
Anstrengungen müssten sich darauf
konzentrieren eine Blockade der Insel
durch die chinesische Marine zu
verhindern eine ständige Nachschublinie
mit den westlichen Verbündeten zu
gewährleisten und gleichzeitig den
feindlichen Landungsversuch zu
verhindern oder zu vereiteln das Problem
um diese Ziele zu erreichen sind
Fähigkeiten erforderlich die nicht gut
zu der Ausrüstung passen die das
taiwanesische Militär anschafft wir
werden über dieses Problem hier auf
visual poliitik schon bald ein separates
Video drehen also vergesst bitte nicht
das Abo falls es euch interessiert 6
März 2023 Taiwan braucht eine neue
Verteidigungsstrategie um mit China
fertig zu werden amerikanische Experten
kritisieren dass Taiwan zu viel für
teure Güter ausgebe anstatt große
Schiffe Flugzeuge und Panzer zu kaufen
und zu bauen die von chinesischen
Raketen leicht ausgeschaltet werden
können sollte Taiwan ihrer Meinung nach
munitionsreserven Anlegen und billigere
mobilere Waffen kaufen die
stromverteidigung fackelt Taiwans
Militär ab Taiwan sollte seine
bestehenden Streitkräfte und alle
zukünftigen Investitionen überprüfen ein
großer Teil seines sicherheitsbudgets
wird für Fähigkeiten verwendet die die
ersten Minuten eines Krieges nicht
überleben oder die kaum in der Lage sind
eine Invasion abzuwehren nach den
Erfahrungen in der Ukraine hat
Washington begonnen die Verteidigung
Taiwans sehr viel ernster zu nehmen
damit die mangelnde Abschreckung
aufgrund von unvorbereittheit nicht zu
einer Invasion führt die die USA zum
Krieg zwingät genau aus diesem Grund
teilte beiden dem Kongress im September
2023 mit dass er seine präidialen
Befugnisse nutzen würde um das Modell
der Militärhilfe für die Insel teilweise
zu ändern so wird die Regierung beiden
direkte Lieferung von militärischer
Ausrüstung aus den eigenen Beständen der
us-stitkräfte Vornehmen dies wird nicht
nur einige wichtige Lieferungen
beschleunigen sondern den Amerikanern
auch enorme Macht geben um zu
entscheiden was in die Meerenge
geschickt wird und damit die
taiwanesische Strategie beeinflussen und
die Frage ist inwi weit die
Kriegserfahrungen in der Ukraine etwas
damit zu tun haben passt gut auf denn
die Verbindung zu Kiev könnte den
Ausschlag dafür gegeben haben dass
Taiwan auf Platz 1 der Prioritätenliste
steht
Ukraine wenn es hart auf hart
kommt ich denke es ist kein Geheimnis
dass die USA seit der russischen
Invasion in der Ukraine eine riesige
Menge an Waffen nach Europa geschickt
haben wir sprechen hier vom größten
Hilfsplan für den alten Kontinent seit
dem marshallpl seit dem Beginn der
russischen Invasion im Februar letzten
Jahres haben die USA der ukrainischen
Regierung mehr als 75 Milliarden Dollar
an Hilfe zukommen lassen natürlich wurde
ein großer Teil Hilfe dazu verwendet
eine gigantische Menge an Waffen und
Munition zu liefern allerdings ist die
Solidarität der USA möglicherweise nicht
unbegrenzt viele Republikaner des
trumpschen Flügels sind der Meinung dass
die Hilfe für Kiev übertrieben sei 27
Oktober 2023 Zweifel an der ukrainehilfe
Johnson will sie aus dem Gesetzentwurf
zur Unterstützung Israels streichen wir
werden Sie nicht im Stich lassen fügte
Johnson der Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses über die Ukraine
hinzu aber wir haben eine Verantwortung
eine Verantwortung als Verwalter des
wertvollen Schatzes des amerikanischen
Volkes und wir müssen sicherstellen dass
das Weiße Haus den Menschen eine gewisse
Rechenschaft über die Dollars gibt die
Regierung beiden möchte dass der
Kongress weitere 61 Milliarden Dollar
für die Ukraine bewilligt 61 Milliarden
sind eine Menge Geld aber eigentlich
handelt es sich gar nicht um einen so
großen Betrag zumindest nicht für die
riesige
[Musik]
US-Wirtschaft in mancher Hinsicht war
der Krieg in der Ukraine für die USA
relativ billig vor allem wenn wir die
Ergebnisse berücksichtigen die diese
Hilfe hervorbringt jeder Dollar in der
Ukraine wird mit einem riesigen Hebel
für die USA eingesetzt und denk dran
dass nicht nur wie das Sagen s selbst
der republikanische Senatsvorsitzende
Mitch
mcon wenn ihr euch die ukrainehilfe
anschaut lasst uns darüber reden wohin
das Geld wirklich fließt ein
beträchtlicher Teil davon wird in den
USA in 38 verschiedenen staten
ausgegeben um die Waffen die wir in die
Ukraine geschickt haben durch modernere
Waffen zu ersetzen damit wir unsere
industrielle Basis wieder aufbauen
können es fällt mir schwer daran etwas
auszusetzen und was den politischen
Pragmatismus angeht er hat recht wenn
wir über Realpolitik sprechen erwei sich
dieser Krieg für die USA als sehr billig
gemessen am bruttoindanprodukt hat er
nur
0,18% der Ausgaben für militärische
Ausrüstung und 0,3% der Gesamtausgaben
verursacht aber warum Schein dann so
viele Republikaner so große Probleme
damit zu haben nun das Problem ist dass
ihre Einwende eigentlich gar nicht
direkt mit der Militärhilfe selbst
Zusammenhängen sondern mit den
Bedingungen unter denen sie geleistet
wird
ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass vom
ersten Tag an beiden die präsidiale
Autorität für das ausländische
militärfinanzierungsprogramm für
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine inne hat
das ist auch ganz logisch denn die
Waffen mussen so schnell wie möglich
geliefert werden ansonsten wäre Russland
mit der Invasion durchgekommen das
Problem ist allerdings dass dies dazu
geführt hat dass die Transparenz nicht
so groß ist es gab nur wenige
Informationen über frachtlieferung und
Lieferanten in gewisser Weise wurde die
Hilfe unter einer Art Grauschleier
geleistet was die Republikaner scharf
kritisiert haben aber denkt mal einen
Moment darüber nach in Anbetracht des
Krieges der gerade geführt wird wäre es
für die USA vielleicht nicht sehr
sinnvoll gewesen die erfolgten
Lieferungen öffentlich und detailliert
anzukündigen eine gewisse Geheimhaltung
verschafft einem im Krieg ja schon einen
Vorteil oder aber ein weiterer
Kritikpunkt besteht darin dass die
Transfers die eigenen waffenbestände des
us-mitärs zu stark reduziert hätten und
diese könnten angesichts des aktuellen
Produktionsniveaus der us-mitärindustrie
erst nach einiger Zeit wieder aufgefüllt
werden und darüber hinaus verbinden die
Republikaner die Militärhilfe auch noch
mit innenpolitischen Forderungen nämlich
bezüglich der Grenzsicherung gegenüber
Mexiko sie machen ihre Zustimmung zur
Militärhilfe also vom entgegenkomm den
Demokraten in der einwanderungsfrage
abhängig und tatsache ist dass all diese
wachsenden politischen Spannungen
zusammen mit einer gewissen
kriegsmütigkeit dazu geführt haben dass
die Amerikaner insbesondere die
Republikaner und unabhängige die weitere
Zusammenarbeit mit der Ukraine immer
weniger unterstützen natürlich bereitet
dies der Regierung beiden am Vorabend
eines neuen Wahljahres noch größere
Kopfzerbrechen und als wäre das nicht
schon genug haben die USA seit dem 7
Oktober auch noch einen neuen konfliktht
am Hals also wohin steuern die USA im
Gazakrieg und ist dieser Konflikt eine
Art vergifteter Apfel für die Regierung
beiden hört jetzt gut
zu Israel der letzte
Tropfen wie sagt es bereits der
Volksmund ein Unglück kommt selten
allein wenn die Dossiers und Treffen im
Pentagon schon den forungen von taipe
und Kiev nicht gerecht werden konnten
stellte der Angriff der Hamas auf Israel
am 7 Oktober den letzten Strohalm
da Außenminister Anthony blinken muss
sich jetzt nicht nur mit der neuen
Zusammenarbeit mit Taiwan und den
wachsenden Spannungen im Zusammenhang
mit einer hypothetischen chinesischen
Invasion auseinandersetzen nein er muss
auch der Drohung der Republikaner die
Finanzmittel für die Ukraine zu
blockieren und mit dem was der
israelische Premierminister Benjamin
Netanyahu als Israels zweiten
Unabhängigkeitskrieg bezeichnet hat aus
auseinandersetzen dennoch ist der Weg
zumindest in diesem Fall besser
vorgezeichnet die USA und Israel sind
sehr enge Verbündete und seit November
1983 gibt es eine gemeinsame
politischmitärische Gruppe die jährlich
Hilfsprogramme zwischen den beiden
Ländern ausarbeitet und beschließt all
dies geschieht in der Regel durch vom
Kongress genehmigte Abkommen oder in
bescheideneren Fällen auf
administrativer Ebene wie bei der
Weitergabe von überschüssigen
Waffen tatsächlich ist Israel das Land
das in den letzten 10 Jahren die meisten
militärischen Überschüsse von den USA
erhalten hat weit weit mehr als die
Fähigkeiten die im Rahmen dies Systems
an Taiwan oder die Ukraine übertragen
wurden darüber hinaus hatten die USA
nach offiziellen Angaben bis Oktober
2023 fast 600 Verträge mit Israel über
F35 Kampflugzeuge ch53k
schwerguthubschrauber K c46a
Tankflugzeuge und präzisionsgelenkte
Munition und die Finanzierung dieser
Lieferverträge übernimmt in vielen
Fällen der US-Steuerzahler um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben es wird
geschätzt dass die USA Israel seit 1948
mehr als 130 Milliarden Dollar an
bilateraler Hilfe zuur Verfügung
gestellt haben und wenn man die
Inflation berücksichtigt wären dies zu
heutigen Preisen etwa 260 Milliarden
Dollar aber selbst das ist natürlich
noch nicht
alles wie wir euch hier auf
visualpolitik bereits berichtet haben
hat die Regierung beiden ihre
Anstrengungen sogar noch verstärkt weil
die Gefahr besteht dass sich ein
größerer Konflikt entwickelt in den
hisbalah Syrien oder sogar der Iran
verwickelt sind sie schickt starke
Truppenkontingente und schiffsverbände
direkt in die Region und erhöht auch die
militärische Unterstützung Israels wir
reden über ein zusätzliches Hilfspaket
von mindestens 14 Milliarden Dollar ihr
seht also das sind die drei heißesten
und zugleich kältesten Konflikte in
denen Washington bis zum Halse steckt
und es ist lange her dass das US-Militär
in Bezug auf seine munitions und
waffenvorräte so stark unter Druck stand
und die Frage ist inwie weit sollten die
USA eurer Meinung nach Taiwan die
Ukraine und Israel unterstützen welche
Priorisierung würdet ihr wählen wie
immer sind wir auf eure Sichtweise und
Kommentare zu diesem Thema schon michtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dies Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns
bitte ein Like und teilt mit euren
Freunden um es auch mit Ihnen zu
diskutieren natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns Hal dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen und Katzenfutter zu
kaufen den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video mach's gut
und bis
[Musik]
bald